cunning liar enigmatic and fearsome are
just a few words used to describe a
particular member of the scp foundation
while many of the foundations
researchers and scientists are a pretty
unusual bunch to say the least this one
might just take the cake and then might
have said cake decommissioned in the
most collaterally damaging way
imaginable similar to the infamous dr
bright always switching bodies appearing
with all manner of ever shifting faces
genders and even species this particular
foundation department head is also no
stranger to never looking the same way
twice in his case he can't be
photographed properly at least not by
any conventional means thanks to some
unknown anomalous augmentation any
pictures taken of this researcher will
have the face swapped with that of a
random animal however these pictures
will always feature the same
characteristic grin much like the smile
of a cheshire cat a notorious liar not
to be trusted by anyone dr alto clef is
one of the scp foundation's strangest
members of personnel for starters dr
alto clef isn't even technically his
real name more a nickname that became
synonymous with the mysterious scientist
and served as a convenient shorthand for
his alleged real name you see according
to the entity most commonly known as dr
cleff his real name is actually a sound
unpronounceable by human beings his name
is apparently the a major chord played
on a ukulele this explains why the
strange doctor always carries the
instrument around with him should anyone
wish to refer to him using his real name
on a strum of those strings in fact he
used to go by a completely different
name the ukulele man and sometimes agent
ukulele thanks to his predilection for
playing the string instrument so where
did the alto clef nickname come from
well that one's easy dr cleff received
this nickname thanks to his pension for
signing off reports with a hand-drawn
alto clef symbol a type of musical note
dr kleff had long been one of the more
enigmatic and mysterious scientists
working at the foundation he is perhaps
more of an oddity than the elusive and
infamous o5 council themselves although
that one is probably up for debate alto
clef was formerly an operative for the
global occult coalition although he
first attracted the attention of the scp
foundation a while before then a number
of research papers clef published at a
redacted university happened to catch
the foundation's eye mostly for their
bizarre and lurid subject matter much of
the content and even the title of some
of his works are redacted but what we do
know is that one of clef's papers
describes certain traits that matched an
existing scp they had catalogued in
their archive there was no way this
could have been a coincidence somehow
alto clef had knowledge of the anomalous
and had to be considered a potential
risk to security during a conversation
with the agent that was sent to
investigate his strange research papers
alto clef was able to convince her to
offer him a job within the foundation it
seems exceptionally unusual that clef
was able to pull this off as most women
working for the scp foundation have
reported that the man possesses a
positively slimy personality so why even
bother to hire this guy if he seems to
be such a creep well it turned out that
the acquisition of dr clef wasn't
without its advantages namely the
capture and containment of scp-447
this scp for anyone who might be
unfamiliar is an anomaly in two parts
the first
scp-447-1 is a sphere composed entirely
of a green slime-like substance it's
warm to the touch the same sort of heat
as an ordinary human body and has no
adverse or harmful effects on anyone
that comes into contact with it
scp-447-2 is a viscous green slime that
is excreted by the main ball this
excretion can be eaten or can increase
the fuel efficiency of gasoline by 150
percent when they are mixed the sphere
and the substance are only known to be
harmful when they come into contact with
dead bodies although what exactly occurs
when this happens has been redacted by
the o5 council nonetheless dr alto clef
was reportedly instrumental in
retrieving scp-447
and given the usefulness of its slime to
the foundation the doctor had in turn
proved his own worth the consensus seems
to be that while his personality might
be annoying or even outright repulsive
in some instances alto clef is still
able to perform his job with precision
and competence making the doctor a
useful asset to the scp foundation
during his time there clef became well
known for being somewhat of a gun
enthusiast as well in fact he earned his
own brand of infamy for his habit of
brutally decommissioning dangerous scps
and you can probably guess what we mean
by that in other words clef established
himself as the foundation's go-to
executioner sometimes he's a little too
good at his job though in one instance
clef brought a chainsaw to work that he
thought possessed supernatural
properties however this happened to take
place at the foundation's annual costume
party causing the doctor to think that a
riot was taking place thanks to
personnel all being dressed as d-class
chainsaw in hand clef murdered half of
his own research staff without a second
thought it also turned out that the
chainsaw hadn't had any anomalous
properties in the first place that was
an hr nightmare dr cleff is renowned for
having brutal efficiency not shying away
from causing the deaths of countless
civilian lives during his
decommissioning of anomalies as long as
he is able to kill or contain an scp to
further the course of science or protect
the majority of the civilian world then
clef will view any possible deaths and
collateral damage caused by his actions
as acceptable losses in short he is a
necessary evil but perhaps clef's best
known attempt at decommissioning an
anomaly was during the
scp-239 incident also known by the
nickname of the witch child
scp-239 might appear to be a harmless
eight-year-old child but she's actually
a powerful reality-bending anomaly with
impervious indestructible skin her
capabilities are almost limitless and
she can influence the world and people
around her in virtually any way that she
can imagine as long as she is conscious
and can see her surroundings
scp-239 can create living matter or make
it disappear wishing things into or out
of existence with as little as a simple
thought or as her file in the scp
archive puts it if she can see it she
can change it although scp-239 was being
contained by the foundation given a
pre-approved list of spells that she was
allowed to perform and kept calm at all
times so she wouldn't think to cause
harm to herself or anyone around her dr
clef didn't think that this was adequate
enough in a report he claimed that the
witch child's containment wasn't
suitable and that she posed a major
security risk to the scp foundation and
its personnel you see given his time
with the global occult coalition dr
kleff had become somewhat of an expert
in anomalies with the ability to reshape
reality making him particularly wary of
scp-239
it was his proposal that the foundation
should not overestimate its own ability
to contain these reality benders and
that they should instead strike first dr
kleff's idea was simple use some form of
sharp implement to kill scp-239
of course given the witch child's
impenetrable skin this is a lot easier
said than done but clef had a few
solutions handy to work around this
firstly his plan was that this
decommissioning would be carried out at
night when scp-239 was asleep and as a
result her reality altering powers would
be neutralized second the implement used
to kill her would be made out of scp-148
the telekill alloy this anomaly is a
metal that the foundation keeps stored
in blocks that has the unique property
of being able to block telepathic and
memetic effects now that plan on its own
might sound fine on paper that is if
you're on board with murdering an
eight-year-old scp while she's asleep
you monster but there were a number of
risks for clef to consider
scp-239 could wake up during her
termination and would then be able to
resist being killed but another far more
complicated risk was that scp-239 could
wake up perceive the person carrying out
her termination as a friend as someone
who wouldn't harm her and her abilities
would then alter the world around her to
make this the case changing reality to
match to try and avoid this outcome dr
cleff volunteered himself as the one who
would carry out the procedure
with his mysterious past dealing with
reality changing anomalies as a member
of the global occult coalition he
overzealously thought he was the only
man cut out for the job however in his
arrogance clef made the fatal mistake of
transmitting his plan openly to
foundation personnel instead of using
secure encrypted channels you see over
time scp-239 had formed bonds with a
number of the site-17 staff that had
been assigned to her regardless of
whether staff members had sympathy
towards the girl or because her
perception of them had altered reality
and bent their intentions dr kondraki
had to step in and intervene and of
course this led to an altercation
between the two
thanks to kondraki's efforts dr cleff's
proposed plan of decommissioning scp-239
a defenseless anomalous child was
thwarted even so during the incident
clef showed how remarkably and
whirringly easy he found it to outwit
the foundation's defenses and security
forces though he walked away from his
attempted murder of scp-239 with a few
severe injuries clef's career wasn't
impeded upon in the slightest in fact
the o5 council promoted him to the
position of department head for the scp
foundation's division of training and
development thanks to his reputation for
swift relentless and surgically precise
methods of terminating scps however dr
kleff's actions during the scp-239
incident prompted some within the
foundation to take a closer look at his
past a tricky thing to do especially
seeing as clef is known to be a liar and
not someone to be trusted and that this
has been a long time habit of his that
is unlikely to change however there does
exist a service record for a global
occult coalition operative who used to
go by the code name of ukulele first
recruited into the coalition in 1981
ukulele was reported to have killed a
number of known threat entities or ktes
but these usually came with the result
of heavy casualties including the deaths
of other goc operatives one colonel
richard adams is quoted in ukulele's
service record as saying does anyone
know who this guy is or where he came
from he's good at what he does right but
every time i ask him about his past i
get a completely different answer
eventually after 99 confirmed kills of
anomalous entities the operative known
as ukulele expressed a desire to return
from active service within the coalition
this request was granted and some time
later he resurfaced working for the scp
foundation under a new name
dr alto clef naturally dr clef has never
confirmed nor denied that he is in fact
ukulele although his habit of playing
the instrument does seem to imply that
there is some sort of connection there
after all that's not as strange as some
of the other rumors floating around
about our old friend alto clef some
think he's an incarnation of the devil
himself or that he even married a
goddess and had several children with
her others claim clef is the biological
father of scp-166
a girl with dear horns and the ability
to make anything man-made corrode then
again you'd be better off coming up with
your own answer than asking dr cleff
about his past he's hardly likely to
give you a straight answer providing he
doesn't accidentally kill you on the
spot now go check out scp foundation
boss the administrator explained and scp
immortal dr bright explained for more of
the inside scoop on the mysterious
figures behind the scp foundation